this is six it'll seriously gonna take
me a second in fact it's barely worth
two marks that it has it's only worth
too much because it makes people scratch
their head and it's a sort of out of
let's turn like that what do you do that
where's what formula do I use for this
okay so they tell you here's what they
me and I tell you that there's this
graph and then I give you a geometric
construction I think that's the tricky
part the people aren't used to just
taking things and moving them around
right it says that is rotated 90 degrees
anti-clockwise about the origin okay so
you'll catch all those bits right number
one it's rotated 90 degrees okay number
two it's anti-clockwise and number three
it's about the origin okay a lot of you
missed one or five or two of these
factors and that sort of messed up your
answer okay so 90 degrees well actually
that's not again anti-clockwise for me
the easiest one to think about okay so
I'm going that way around the clock
okay I'm going backwards on the clock
and I'm going 90 degrees okay so where
am I going to end up if I'm going about
the origin
don't say a point like this right well
you're gonna end up with this base 90
degrees okay so here's a way to think
about it I used to be hugging the y-axis
that used to you might have some time to
since I take the whole thing during 90
degrees right my ass in turn also goes
90 degrees 90 degrees from the licensor
sorry the y axis is the x axis so that's
why I'm hugging this down okay now what
does that look like it's got the same
kind of logarithm shape and because been
rotated right it's now looking more like
an exponential okay it's not exponential
growth because it's getting smaller this
is actually what I call exponential
decay which is it's all about topping
later this year okay so it's like an
exponential so it's like to the power or
something I choose to
because that says to write and I haven't
stretched it out or anything like that
but because it's getting smaller as X
gets larger it's not to do the exits to
the negative x okay and you guys know
when you put a minus on the front of an
X term right it just rips things around
right horizontally just like if you put
a minus in front of the Y it will flip
them vertically okay so that's it
okay yeah I chose this base too because
of this base to if I want a different
base that would imply that this has been
squashed
sorry squashed or stretched or changing
some other dimensional way okay all
right now 7/7 has a few more chops on it
than six okay it just it just looks
intimidating which is part of the point
it's meant to it's the last question
what do you do with it all right
it says 2 to the 2x plus 4 plus K lots
of 2x minus 1 is equal to 0 ok now I
throw you a big hint by saying using the
quadratic formula so at least you know
sort of you're in one direction that
there's going to be a quadratic equation
there that's it can you see it so low
it's an equation reducible to a
quadratic and then you have to show this
read properly ok so how do we go about
this if I want to use the quadratic
formula on this I've got to get it into
a form that makes it clearer
what kind of quadratic it is so you can
probably see what an appropriate
substitution would be instead of X's
next square is another thing I've got 2
to the X ok so that means that there's a
2 to the X hiding in here I need to
rewrite it a little bit it's
deliberately written so it's not obvious
so you actually have to twist it around
a little okay so let's um let's go after
this okay 2 to the power of 2x plus 4
the first okay how do I rewrite it
all right sir I'll go to Nick's here and
I can break it apart I'll look for the
two before out the front if that's okay
with you and then to the 2x okay now I
can do what better than that right
before I move on to the rest of the line
I want a to the X not to the 2x okay
but that's good because the first turn
this is a this is an accretion equation
reducible to a quadratic right the first
term should be this one squared right
constant and then x and then x squared
yeah so over here I'm gonna rewrite that
2 to the 2x as to the x squared okay
just to make it really obvious when
actually solving for plus K lots of 2 to
the X minus 1 equals 0 all right now the
question says use the quadratic formula
and I've done enough work to actually
put it in that form you can say let u
equal to this and then substitute in
that kind of thing but it's not really
necessary because I can immediately say
at this point 2 to the x equals and
start off on the quadratic formula okay
because this is in the general form okay
what's the quadratic formula minus B
which in this case is K plus or minus
the square root of okay what are we
gonna be squared which is okay square
minus 4ac minus 4ac okay so minus 4
what a yeah so 2 to the 4 is 16 16 this
is promising by the way because the
thing you're actually asked to prove it
has a 64 in it okay tick I'm in the
right direction for a and then C is just
negative 1 okay so that'll cancel out
the UM donated all on to a 2 to the 5
that's day 2
all right so let me just neaten this up
a little bit before I making statements
about this solution I've got minus K
plus or minus because I expect two
solutions K squared plus 64 on 32 okay
now here's one of the reasons why it's
actually more helpful to not do the
substitution and say let you introduce a
new letter U and then start working with
it because when you see that you're
solving for 2 to the X not this mystical
magical you you've just plunged it up
from nowhere okay so the X has some
important properties most notably if you
think about what - dibbs looks like this
graph is always positive okay it never
touches the axis let alone goes below it
okay so that means when you look at this
answer I should have - appear I can
exclude one of the answers okay and you
should know you have to exclude one
because the thing you're trying to prove
only has one solution not - okay so I
would say at this point next line I'd
say but as I argue graphically over here
right - to the X is greater than zero
okay if you want to be really really far
you can say to the X is greater than
zero for real values of X because in
theory if use clinics numbers you would
get negatives but that's therefore to
the X cannot equal one of these values
namely the negative one right I know
it's negative because it's minus
something - something else
and even if K were negative this would
still make the whole thing negative okay
so this is gonna be unfettered - so
there's my exclusion of one of the
solutions this is a crucial point okay I
think this is worth three marks this
would be one of them okay therefore sued
the X is equal to minus K plus
this business only okay now that is the
quadratic formula that's run its course
but it's not what we wanted to prove
right they wants to prove that X is
equal to something not to the X okay so
what do I have to do to this to make X
the subject it's an index and if you
oppose it to all have to do is rework it
so it's a long equation right because I
want so I say X is equal to log base two
of all that okay
I'm dividing here so that's equivalent
to subtracting log base two of that
thing which is exactly what we want from
the tree - the denominator and that's a
five that's in the question